foreign
let's start with the debate now and of
course when one talks of certainty
what's lurking around is skepticism so
the first the first question is can we
be certain of anything and if so what
and I'd like to start with Simon please
um
I think well I've already said in my
intro that I think we can be certain of
lots of things
and if you can be certain about when the
bus is coming
um and that's just an example
I'd just like to pick up on some of the
phrases Hillary used
um
he said we can't refer to that language
doesn't permit us to refer to stuff out
there now I presume that out there is
metaphorical for something because in
the ordinary sense we can certainly
refer to things that are out there
um I go sailing with friends and if you
go sailing you pick up a nautical chart
and it tells you what's out there quite
literally what's in front of your boat
and if you don't use the chart and if
you don't know what the symbols mean
you're going to get into a lot of
trouble
so there are symbols they do manage to
refer to what's out there
the rocks for example
um and
we do know how to use them so somehow
language or symbolic representation
pulls off this trick of putting us in
touch with the world that's out there
now Hillary might have meant
and perhaps this is I think a richer
vein to explore that we are in the
position which really can't left us in
that we can know a lot about how things
appear to us to be
but we can't know that Ding and Zeke the
thing in itself the thing behind the
appearances
and that's the idea of a kind of veil of
perception or perception giving you only
surface representations of the
underlying reality
now whatever can't thought I think
there's some evidence for this after all
if you look at say
um
uh of the salt on your table
uh all you all you see is sort of white
crystals
um what's it what's underneath what is
that sense is out there is for example
sodium chloride but you may not know
that nobody knew it until the
development of chemistry in the 18th
century so it's something that takes
patient investigation but that
investigation can be successful
chemistry can tell us a lot about what's
out there just as much as nautical
charts can tell us what's out there so I
think be very careful of using the
generalization what's out there as a
suggestion of Mystery it needn't suggest
mystery can suggest perfectly tractable
problems whose solution gives us
certainty about what's out there do you
think that certainty or approximately
certain and I and I wonder whether
that's your disagreement with the
between Hillary and Simon I don't know
um
I I think it's bad philosophy
unfortunately as as has been said
already perhaps suggested by Descartes
to manufacture unreal doubts
um I think any doubt about whether the
stuff on your table is sodium chloride
would be quixotic and um I mean why
waste your time on bizarre conjectures
like that
science fictions as it were and I don't
really see why philosophers should
prioritize that kind of rather in a
sense silly sort of Doubt when there's
so much going for one story and so
little going for any other
if you're coming from is it that you're
kind of using an extreme doubt or or are
you coming from a different perspective
on this well I'm not motivated by the
same uh same things that Descartes was
being motivated it's not I'm trying to
reach some uh some certainty in that
sense because in fact my criticism of uh
uh philosophical realism is more
profound than that
Simon and I have had these conversations
over the years and I obviously had many
conversations with philosophical
realists uh I think that you know I can
point to the fact that
um uh when I first put forward this a
look that we should think of reality as
being open it was it was quite out there
uh in a different meaning to the word
that we previously used for out there
um but in recent time uh Neuroscience I
would K would argue has moved in my
direction there are now
um a lot of neuroscientists across the
globe in uh in prestigious universities
who who take the view that reality is
what we take to be reality is a function
of how the brain is operating and the
processes that are going on and a
representation to ourselves and it's not
a representation of what's out there now
I am a great advocate of checking to see
whether your way of holding the world
works or not so in a in an odd sort of
way I'm an arch rationalist you know I'm
in the Contemporary World there are many
aspects of it in this sort of postmodern
space where people in imagine that you
can hold all sorts of views you don't
have to look very carefully about how
they apply and and there's a casual
attitude to empiricism and rationalism
indeed uh criticisms of it but I don't I
don't hold that view at all I think that
we have to look very carefully at what
we say and see whether the world uh does
um operate in the light of holding it
like that so hold this framework at work
with it and and does it do uh what it
it's it's proposed to do does it enable
you to intervene in the way that yeah it
does but you shouldn't imagine that
you've got to the end of it they're
going to be a whole load of other people
who are going to come along with
different ways of accounting for this
and the idea that you know if you look
at a crystal of um sort that it is
sodium chloride I think is a mistake I
think that you can indeed see it as
sodium chloride that's the function of
the periodic table the way that we
developed chemistry it's very powerful
it's amazingly successful it's an
enormously powerful model but there are
many other ways of thinking of salt it
can be a great seasoning and perhaps
different types of salt uh generate a
better seasoning and maybe you it's more
useful for you if you are a cook to
think of it in terms of the vocabulary
of seasoning rather than in the
vocabulary of sodium chloride and these
different ways of holding the world are
often not incompatible of course I'm not
saying they are incompatible sometimes
they are incompatible but that doesn't
matter because what's going on is they
are ways of holding the openness of
reality thank you I would like to listen
to here what Ruth has to say about that
if you have any thoughts on yeah what
Hillary and Simon are trying to digest
what's happening here
um so I just wonder what so yes of
course
salt can be understood as sodium
chloride it can be understood as
seasoning or that magical ingredient to
your pot roast or whatever
of course that's true the question is
whether the right way to understand all
those claims I just made depend on this
view in the seminar right the view in
the seminar is the world is open right
or
sorry I'm not gonna I don't know what
your view about the natural is but
forget about
um
forget about the stuff in the seminar
room right
I think both of these gentlemen agree
that there are you know just common
sense you can represent things in lots
of different ways and we want to be able
to do things with our representations
that meet our goals allow us to flourish
and so on
um so I implore
us to leave the idea of uncertainty or
certainty in the seminar out of this
discussion what we should talk about is
the kind of uncertainty that we face in
our lives the uncertainty with the small
you and try to figure out should we you
know what kind of impact does that have
on our lives should we try to pursue
certainty in the kitchen
and if not
what should we be doing instead
suppose you you're going to the hardware
store
all right you're at the hardware store
and you think oh did I leave the lights
on in the house and you're uncertain as
to whether you left the lights on in the
house but then you start to replay
you're leaving the house oh yeah I think
I might have switched them off
you can be what philosophers call
Practically certain
that you turned off the lights in the
house because with respect to what
matters right the degree of credence you
need in order to be certain it depends
on what turns on whether or not you left
the lights on the house okay the bill
will be a little bit higher maybe you
contribute to global warming that's very
different than if you're contemplating
oh no did I leave Junior in the car in
the parking lot right with the windows
rolled up there you need a higher degree
of credence in order to be practically
certain that you didn't do that so we
can be certain we can be practically
certain about a huge number of things
and if we're not practically certain in
this way we can't get on in life to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV